and seamlessly they've appeared today
and the stage is set up so please put
your hands together and thank you
[Applause]
thank you to all of you for attending
these hustings are for us the members of
the conservative party to take part in a
great exercise of democracy where we get
to choose our new party leader
she or he will be announced on the 5th
of september and as with the party of
government will become prime minister
very soon afterwards
as ian dale who moderated the hustings
in 2019 said
i found chairing the hustings a
surprisingly positive experience
the members really put the two
candidates through their paces and asked
some very searching questions
so i ask you today to make your
questions searching
to make them succinct and to ask
questions and not to make statements
and one question each please so that
more of the audience have an opportunity
to grill our candidates
both of our candidates have a duty and a
desire to fulfill our 2019 manifesto
their differences will be how to go
about that
in a very different world from 2019
post brexit post covered in uncertain
times internationally
look at ukraine and taiwan
and whereas you know here our union as a
nation is being challenged
so i'm sure you'll want to test our
candidates to seek to establish their
strengths and to see who you think is
capable of running our great country
as we're all conservatives here i know
that you all be respectful of our two
candidates
and keep your questions positive
there are just over two weeks left to
vote
if you haven't already voted then you
can cast your vote online or by post
it's very easy to vote online or you can
choose traditional snail mail
and if you do post then please remember
to put a stamp on your envelope
and please note that there are planned
postal strikes towards the end of this
month
so it's actually easier to vote online
and safer
i hope that all of you will go away
enthused and energized in your
commitment to helping our party win the
next election
we need your help and support
and finally i'd like to remind everyone
that at the end of our democratic
process
we must come together as a party
we have many new members who should be
contacted and make welcome we have
members returning to the fold and we
must make use of their talents
ours has to be a combined effort
under our new leader to go forward to
victory at the next election
all of our fifty shades of blue who make
up our party must come together to
defeat labour the liberal democrats and
the nationalists with a team spirit to
defend our union
so ladies and gentlemen without further
ado let's get on with the show
[Applause]
well thank you uh peter good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen it's a real
pleasure to be back in northern ireland
as chairman of the conservative party
i say back in northern ireland because i
have close family ties here my
mother-in-law lives just down the road
in bangor so it's a real pleasure to be
back and to see so many
faces so many members of our party here
today to hear from the two candidates
before i invite our first candidate on
the stage to give her opening statement
can i just see a show of hands to make
sure that everybody here who is a
eligible voting member has received
their ballot paper
great
and can i also see a show of hands for
how many people are still yet to vote
amazing excellent so there are a lot of
eligible members here still waiting to
vote still hopefully waiting to be
convinced by our two fantastic
candidates
the way this will be working as has just
been set out by peter we will invite the
first candidate on the stage to make
their opening statement it will be liz
trust going first she will make an
opening statement and then i will come
back on stage and invite questions from
the floor
if you want to ask a question we'll go
straight into questions after the
opening statement if you raise your hand
clearly so i can see you i will then
signal to one of the people wearing the
very fashionable white hoodies to come
over to you with a microphone at the
start of the question if you can say who
you are and where you're from and then
if you can ask your question if you can
keep your question brief that would be
very much appreciated the brief for the
questions the more of you will get an
opportunity to ask a question
so with no further ado will you please
give a warm welcome to the first
candidate liz trust
hi everybody it's fantastic to be here
in northern ireland
i was brought up in paisley in scotland
in leeds in yorkshire
so i guess you could say i'm a child of
the union
and
i
believe that our union
is one of the key assets we have as a
country we're not just neighbours
we're family
and i want our family to stay together
and never ever to split up
a northern ireland
is a key
part
of our fantastic union and ever since
i've been a minister
in this government
i've worked on behalf of the people of
northern ireland
as daphra secretary i've been to the
balmoral show i've promoted our
fantastic
farm products here from northern ireland
around the world and as trade secretary
struck dozens of new trade deals to
benefit
the businesses and consumers here in
northern ireland
and since becoming foreign secretary
i have taken on the issue of the
northern ireland protocol
and seek to resolve the issues that we
face
because the fact is
that the protocol is undermining the
belfast good friday agreement
it is causing unfairness
between the communities in northern
ireland and we need to make sure it is
fixed for the future of this great part
of the united kingdom
we need to sort out
the laws the uk needs to be the ultimate
arbiter the uk courts need to be the
ultimate arbiter we need to sort out the
bureaucracy across the irish sea so that
we can see goods flowing freely from
great britain to northern ireland and
that's why i put forward the solution of
the green and the red lanes we also need
to sort out regulation and we need to
make sure that the people of northern
ireland can benefit from the same tax
breaks as the people of great britain
now i worked hard to get a resolution
with the eu on this issue it wasn't
forthcoming but i'm not somebody who's
prepared to let the situation drift
that's why i developed the northern
ireland protocol bill
i pushed it through whitehall we got it
through the house of commons and i am
absolutely determined to deliver it in
full and make sure it's put into place
because this is vital for the future of
northern ireland and the future of the
united kingdom i'm also determined to
make sure we address the issues of
legacy too
we need to make sure
that every part of our gate great
country
thrives and that's about making sure
people have opportunities regardless of
their background regardless of which
part of the united kingdom they're from
we need to become an aspiration nation
but the fact is we do face difficult
economic challenges we do face
a global energy crisis and that is why
we can't have business as usual that is
why we need to be bold see what i will
do is i will unlock the opportunities of
brexit i will make sure that we have
free ports here in northern ireland i
will make sure that we have more trade
deals and i will make sure all of the eu
laws are off our statute books by the
end of 2023
i'll also lower taxes
we shouldn't have put up national
insurance we said we wouldn't in our
manifesto and i will have a temporary
moratorium on the green energy levy to
make sure that customers bills are lower
and as for corporation tax
we shouldn't be putting it up to the
same level as france
and to hire 10 points higher than the
republic of ireland
because that will make it harder to
secure the investment that we need to
into our country
so i will keep corporation tax low
because i believe as a conservative that
we are about
working rewarding people who do the
right thing people who work hard people
who set up their own businesses people
who are self-employed those are the
people whose side we should be on we of
course need to continue to stand up to
vladimir putin
i'm proud that we were the first country
in europe to send weapons to ukraine and
some of those weapons were produced here
in northern ireland the famous end laws
but we also need to make sure
that we are
looking after our defense and security
because
europe is more insecure that's why i
would increase defense spending to 3 of
gdp
over the coming decade
and as foreign secretary i put the
toughest sanctions on russia
of any country in the world
we also need to make sure we're
protecting our country from illegal
immigration
that's why i would legislate to make
sure that the echr cannot overrule
decisions made democratically here in
the united kingdom
and we need to protect freedom and
democracy
here in the united kingdom as well as
overseas there's been too much identity
politics too much talking our country
down
i'm very clear a woman is a woman
and i will make sure
i will make sure we protect our single
sex spaces our domestic violence
shelters and we protect women's rights
but most of all
i will make sure we protect our precious
united kingdom i've shown i can deliver
as trade secretary as foreign secretary
and i now want to deliver for the united
kingdom and i want to deliver with the
northern ireland conservatives i will
make sure they are an integral part of
our campaign they're an integral part of
the work that we do as government so
that we are unlocking potential and
opportunity
right across the united kingdom here in
northern ireland so we can go on and we
can win the general election in 2024.
thank you very much thank you
wonderful um if i can see a show of
hands of who wants to go with the first
question and i'm going to start right at
the back so central there's a gentleman
in a blue shirt there if we can send the
microphone to him
there we go sir yes
catherine uh terry middle from
southampton conservative association i
know in your speech that you didn't
mention the stalemate in stormont
i'd like to ask you if you are elected
prime minister what will you do to
restore a democratic government in this
part of the world that has not held
hostage
over
this saturday or please
well this is exactly what i have been
working on
with the northern ireland protocol bill
because until we sort the issue of the
northern ireland protocol out we are not
going to get stormont back up and
running and i've been this in
discussions with all of the parties in
northern ireland i'm determined to make
it happen and as we make progress on the
northern ireland protocol bill we will
see
power sharing re-established in northern
ireland and as well the belfast good
friday agreement reestablished
thank you and then if we go to another
gentleman central isle um you sir yes
the microphone is just coming to you now
hi thank you for coming to northern
ireland you're very welcome here
i'm irvin armstrong past chair of the
conservative party in northern ireland
and i've been a member of the party
proof for a quarter of a century and
there are others in the audience today
have been here
longer than i have
and we have all worked to promote uh
cross-community politics that believes
in the union and as the only party
organizers in all of the union i think
we haven't had the support in northern
ireland that we have deserved it has
been intermittent there have been deals
with the eup deals with the uup what
commitment would you give to support
both with people and financially the
party to allow to properly develop in
future
well i think you are
absolutely right
that the conservative party of northern
ireland hasn't received the support that
it should have done
over the years and what i'm committed to
is making sure the conservative party of
northern ireland are a key part of my
team
that they get the resources they need to
attract new members and it's great news
that we are seeing more members joining
the conservative party but also that
we're putting more candidates up for
election here in northern ireland
because we are the conservative and
unionist party we believe in the union
and we need to
we need to we need to put put our money
uh where our mouth is and i'd say about
me is that i am somebody who has visited
northern ireland a lot i have visited
scotland a lot i have visited wales a
lot i'm very very committed to
delivering for the whole united kingdom
and i believe in it and i will work with
you to really make things happen for the
conservative party here in northern
ireland
great
and there was another gentleman in the
center aisle here just
wait for
10 seconds later
glenn chambers from east belfast it
doesn't seem that likely to me but if
the eu did come back with some sort of
compromise on the protocol that was
nonetheless well short of the protocol
bill would you accept that and secondly
are we going to have to wait a year for
the protocol bill to actually become law
as it goes through the house of lords
so i will not accept
anything
that doesn't deliver on the key issues i
talked about so
making sure that uk courts are the
ultimate arbiter
making sure that we have free-flowing
east-west trade making sure that the
people of northern ireland can benefit
from the tax benefits uh delivered by
uh the government
the uk government but also sorting out
the regulatory system so businesses can
operate according to uk law or eu law
depending on where the export market is
and that was what i set out to mauro
setkovich at the beginning of the year i
was very clear that that will that is
what was needed to restore the balance
of the belfast good friday agreement and
to get the institutions in northern
ireland back up and running so i won't
accept anything less than that
it might take time to get this bill
through the house of lords but the
sooner this we start the sooner we'll
finish and i'm determined to get it done
as quickly as possible and what i expect
is the house of lords will see the fact
that this bill has got a strong mandate
from the house of commons and they will
understand that this is a priority for
the government to deliver
great
um
i'll go to the gentleman over there
roger gilbert from belfast
um
we've seen over a number of years
uh bull comments about the union
um and when we get a secretary of state
or a prime minister coming in
they automatically end up in the nioh
and kai tai to running us like a
colonial outpost
laterally we've been
actually buying to the wishes of
nationalism
and are now being bossed about by
international bodies
in the eu the republic of ireland and
america
what
if you're elected leader what commitment
can you give to us that can be
demonstrable after you're elected that
you will not cut high and that you will
lay down conservative and unionist
politics in northern ireland
well i i ask you to judge me on my
record
i took on responsibility for negotiating
the northern ireland protocol and
against a lot of advice in whitehall and
against the wishes of
some of the people that you've mentioned
and i would be very clear with people
like nancy pelosi exactly what i think
about this and exactly what we need to
do
i have got on with delivering this
people said it wouldn't be possible
people said we wouldn't be able to get a
mandate in the house of commons we got
that mandate and this bill
is absolutely legal
because we need to do it in order to
restore
the
primacy of the belfast good friday
agreement on every single challenge i
have faced in government
whether it is getting the trade deals
done whether it's the northern ireland
protocol whether it's changing the
sanctions regime i'm not somebody who
has
gone backwards or taken no for an answer
i'm somebody who's got on and delivered
it and i've delivered on every single
promise i've made
wonderful there is a lady over there
with a hand up at the moment if we can
get a microphone
to please
thank you and
northern ireland has a long history of
ship building and has built many
warships current defense spend is 30
pounds per person per capita in northern
ireland this compares with 100 360 per
person per capita in scotland and much
more in england will you commit to
leveling up defence spend in northern
ireland and support the revitalization
of shipbuilding here in belfast
well we we have a fantastic shipbuilding
tradition and a great tradition here in
northern ireland and of course
part of what we need to do is increase
the defense budget which i am committed
to
but we also need to
deliver levelling up and leveling up for
me
is also about making sure
that northern ireland gets the
opportunities it deserves so i talked
earlier about freeports and it's been
too slow frankly to deliver a free port
in northern ireland i'm committed to
doing that i'm committed to
giving northern ireland those tax
benefits so we can see
more opportunities more jobs including
in the shipbuilding industry
great
uh there's a gentleman i think he's got
maybe a yellow handkerchief in his hand
if we can get a microphone to you sir
thank you roger lomas from west tyrone
uh if you're a prime minister it'll be
your choice as to who the next secretary
of state is
will that secretary state like the
secretary of state for scotland and
wales be committed to here in the sense
of will they be accountable to the
electorate or are you just going to give
us another fly-in fly-out absentee
political landlord
well
look
i don't want to be premature we're still
in the middle of this leadership race
and what i can assure you
about everybody
i would a appoint in the cabinet is it
will be based on
how good they are at doing the job and
whether they get things done and we've
been talking today about the important
things we've got to deliver in northern
ireland we've got to deliver the
northern ireland protocol bill we've got
to deliver the free port we've got to
deliver those investment opportunities
in northern ireland and that is
ultimately what people in northern
ireland care about and why people will
vote conservative in northern ireland is
for those reasons so what i can tell you
is i will make sure
the person in that job is the absolute
best at delivering for the people of
northern ireland
great um
there's a gentleman
at the back um there's three of you
together
gentleman with a watch on your hand
yourself will you stand up and the
microphone is coming to you
many people are now turning returning to
cash to balance their household budget
yet many businesses will actually refuse
to accept cash what could you do to
assist those people who prefer to use
cash
well you you are right and
it seems to me some businesses
will only accept cash and some
businesses will only accept cards and
that's that's um but we should make sure
that people are able to use cash where
they don't have alternatives i think
that is important and it's a fair point
great
um
is anyone on the side
no
can we go for the gentleman here in the
red top
microphones coming to you sir
um hi liz i'm george uh i live in south
antrim and i used to lead conservatives
abroad in south korea so uh it's great
to have you over um so in 2019
westminster undemocratically and
unconstitutionally imposed abortion on
northern ireland something which the
vast majority of the people here are
against
so my question is will you if prime
minister be a modern-day william
wilberforce and see abortion abolished
and infanticide ended in our province or
even if not that will you just let the
people of northern ireland have their
say on this issue thank you
well i'm afraid i don't agree with you
uh
i think we need you know we are a united
kingdom
we we are a united kingdom
and we need all of our laws to apply
right across the united kingdom that is
what being a union is
um there's a lady on the front row here
can you put the microphone down
felicity houston from east belfast and
i've been the party even longer than
irwin so i must be in a very young white
sea when i joined
i'd like to ask about something slightly
further afield in northern ireland and
quite relevant to your current portfolio
and you talked about how you've taken
such a robust stance against putin and
and led europe and i think strengthened
the resolve of much of europe to stand
up to him but the next fear i think we
all have is china and taiwan
and the difference i feel between china
and russia is that we are totally meshed
with them could we have sanctions
against china as we did again have
against russia you know would we even be
brave enough to ban tick-tock what are
we going to do if the chinese move into
taiwan
so
china
is becoming
increasingly assertive
china is an authoritarian regime
it is
a very a very deep security concern for
the uk and the rest of the world but
what we need to do is we need to work
with our partners like the japanese and
the americans because there is strength
in numbers if you look at the g7 it
represents 50 of gdp
what i what i've done and i did this in
liverpool where we had our g7 meeting
last year
is encouraged our counterparts to work
together
so we should look at making sure we're
not exporting technology that could be
used against us we need clear investment
screening and we've developed that to
make sure that we can't have
acquisitions of key strategic assets and
we need to be clear that we should not
become strategically dependent on china
in the way that europe became on russia
and they've used it as leverage against
europe in terms of things like turning
off the gas what we're also doing is
working with our g7 counterparts on our
alternative to the belt and road
initiative
because at the moment what china is
doing is it's investing in developing
countries it's creating debt and it's
using that to try and have greater
global influence so we need to work
together
with freedom-loving democracies to
counter that and to make sure we're
investing
into those countries but also we're not
becoming strategically dependent on
china
[Applause]
there's a gentleman here in a fabulous
jacket
hello sorry connor aston i'm just
wondering how you could potentially fix
the benefit system
um if we take a single parent working uh
it gets the stage now as a small
business owner that people can't afford
if they work more than 16 hours a week
they start to affect their benefits and
they then can't afford to do that as a
small business owner it makes it much
more difficult for us to recruit people
so how could you see to reward people to
work rather than to not work well you
you make a very good point and there's
there's a large number of people now
across the united kingdom who are
economically inactive and what we need
to do is encourage
those people
into work and we're also facing
businesses that have a skill shortage at
the same time and it is about changing
the incentives in the benefit system and
that is what i would seek to do
over time to get more people into work
but also
creating the jobs and the opportunities
that
that people can work in and that's why
it's important that we keep taxes low
reverse the national insurance increase
so we help businesses thrive but we're
also helping people
get those jobs by making the incentives
in the benefit system much clearer
great
the gentleman here at the front if we
can get a microphone now just about bear
with me
so it is coming round to you
jack everyone north down we have a huge
deficit um is reducing
taxation
uh the right way forward or not to to
service that debt
so we have the highest levels of tax
for 70 years
and it's my view that if you put taxes
up too high you actually get less
revenue in because businesses are less
likely to invest people are less likely
to set up new companies people are less
likely to go into work
if there aren't clear benefits to doing
so and i think we've got to the stage in
our economy
where taxes are too high and they're
potentially choking off growth currently
we're projected to have a recession and
i don't need to tell you
that if we have a recession
it's going to be harder to pay the
deficit off now of course
over time we need to make sure the
private sector is growing faster than
the public sector and we're bringing
those revenues in but it's my judgment
that our taxes are too high and they're
actually stopping that economic activity
that will help
pay off our debt and pay off our deficit
over time
we've come to the gentleman
gentleman here
microphones coming to you sir
hello um alan thompson carrick fergus
if elected what measures would you take
from day one
to
bring to an end the the fiasco and the
english channel
so
i i fully support the rwanda scheme and
i worked with priti patel on that i want
to expand that scheme to more countries
it is the right solution because what it
ultimately means is there is somewhere
that that people can live and work in
the long term and it's a it is a
long-term sustainable solution
the problem we have is the echr
trying to overrule the decisions made in
britain and the way i would deal with
that is immediately legislating to
make sure that the echr can't overrule
our domestic decisions
um
central isle this gentleman here with
glasses on if um
microphone is coming to you sir bear
with us
hi i'm jack from uh belfast and hi hi
you have supported a prime minister that
has continually lied to the queen
parliament and the entire united kingdom
therefore does this not bring into
question your own personal integrity and
honesty
well i don't i don't agree with that
boris johnson has been an excellent
prime minister he delivered
he delivered on brexit
he delivered on brexit
he delivered on the covert vaccine and
he delivered on standing up to vladimir
putin and backing the ukrainians and i'm
i'm proud of what he did and what we
need to do now
is we need to deliver on the promises we
made in 2019 to people across the united
kingdom and that is what i am determined
to do
fantastic
um
final question we're going to go with
the lady with the scarf on here if the
microphone can come down
mr so welcome to northern ireland
um we have a great country here so much
going for it we just need to get it into
the right hands
i'm just going to come back on you again
about democracy returning to northern
ireland
in
as my friend mentioned about the
abortion issue
um
in 2019 it was the northern executive
formation act that allowed the secretary
of state at the time to bring in this
abortion law now you mentioned that you
would want things to be the same right
across the uk
but it's not the same list
we have an extremely severe abortion law
here in northern ireland
one of the most extreme in the world
i'm a retired occupational therapist and
i'm very concerned
that
babies with club food and hair lip
both can have modern modern surgical
procedures to correct that
are being aborted also that many uh
babies with learning disability um are
are um being aborted and we're a bit
deprived of people with learning
disability in our community that can be
so so wonderful
um
now and there's another issue regarding
um sex education so i'll have to shorten
and come to the point but what can you
do to repeal
um
section nine
um so that
true democracy will be returned to
northern ireland and we can
even link in with the uk on this where
is that the case uh were not
at the same level
well the i mean the
they're slightly different issues
because the
the issue of an abortion of abortion
is an issue of conscience for members of
parliament and i do believe that should
be decided
at a uk level i think that is the right
approach i mean on the issue of sex
education
that is a
different issue that does need to apply
specifically in northern ireland
thank you wonderful thank you
can you please put your hands together
for this truth thank you thanks very
much thank you everybody
thank you
uh thank you very much and can i just
reiterate the point about short
questions the shorter the questions the
more people will get through
will you please now get ready and give a
warm welcome to
our second candidate rishi sunak
good afternoon my fellow britons thank
you for having me now look i'm standing
here in front of you today for one very
simple reason
and it's because our country our united
kingdom did something extraordinary
for my family it welcomed them here as
immigrants 60 years ago and allowed them
to build a better life
now i was raised with a few simple
values foremost among those is that
family means everything to me
and that's because we all know
that the bonds of family are far greater
than anything any government could ever
hope to replicate
now in my family the thing that we
prioritized above all was hard work
as the way to forge ahead
my mom ran the local chemist in
southampton where i grew up
and i spent my time working for her in
the shop out and about delivering
medicines
to local patients but also doing her
books
seeing the power of that small business
to provide jobs and opportunity in our
local community
now for my parents there was one thing
above all that they believe could
provide a better future for their three
children and it was simple
it was through education
and that's why today i passionately
believe that the best way
that we reduce inequality
that we spread opportunity that we
transform people's lives
is by ensuring that the birthright of
every child is a world-class education
and that in a nutshell are my values
patriotism
family
service
hard work
and i know that they will be your values
too and that's because they're
conservative values and that's why i
want to be your prime minister to put
those values into action to build a
better britain
but how are we going to do that well we
need to do three things
first
we must restore trust
and we need to rebuild the economy
and we need to reunite our country
now when it comes to restoring trust for
me
that starts with honesty
and as you can see in this leadership
race i've not chosen to say the things
that people may want to hear
i've said the things that our country i
believe
needs to hear now even though that
doesn't make my life easy
it is honest and that is what leadership
is all about
but we'll also restore trust by
delivering on the things that matter to
people
and that's why i want to stand up for
our values
and take on
this lefty woke culture that seems to
want to cancel our history our values
and our women
it's why i want to make sure that we
finally tackle illegal migration because
i stand here as a product of our
country's compassionate history in
welcoming people but it must be done
fairly it must be done legally and when
we see screen scenes on our tv screens
of people coming here illegally it
undermines trust in the system and with
my plan radical as it is we will fix
that problem and take back proper
control of our borders
but we also need to rest restore trust
right here in northern ireland
because all you know
that northern ireland's place
in the united kingdom is being
threatened
now
the reverend mcmullen had a wonderful
anecdote about david trimble at his
funeral where he talked about the night
of the belfast good friday agreement
how david forgot his pin number for his
card and couldn't buy some food when he
went out shopping
but we also know that david never forgot
the details when it came to negotiation
and as a proud briton unionist and
ulsterman the detail that he was most
proud of when it came to the belfast
good friday agreement
was strand three
the east-west relationship because he
knew that that would be the
counterbalance to what the nationalists
were after
and he had enormous foresight in making
sure that was an integral part of the
agreement and you know as i know that
that is under threat today
and i want to give you
my commitment that i will do what it
takes
to fix the protocol and protect northern
ireland's place in our united kingdom
[Applause]
when it comes to rebuilding the economy
you don't need me to tell you what the
problem is we saw it today in the
figures it's inflation
and we've seen this story before
inflation is the enemy it makes everyone
poorer
eats into people's savings their
pensions it pushes up mortgage rates
that's why this
autumn winter as prime minister i'll
make sure
that we support especially the most
vulnerable in our society
with the means to help get through what
will be a difficult time because that's
the compassionate conservative thing to
do
but what i will not do is pursue
policies that risk making inflation far
worse and lasting far longer because
that is not going to help anyone and
especially if those policies seem to
amount to borrowing 50 billion pounds
and putting that on the country's credit
card then asking our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because for
me that's not right it's not responsible
and it is certainly not conservative
but i
am going to cut taxes and in this
parliament for the first time in 16
years with my plans we will cut income
tax
because i want to demonstrate that under
a conservative government that i lead
hard work will always pay
but i'm going to do that responsibly by
being tough on public spending and by
growing our economy which is why this
autumn i want to radically change how we
tax businesses
cutting taxes for those businesses that
are doing the right thing and investing
and innovating because that's how you
drive growth and productivity in a
modern economy economy
but i also want to support our fantastic
industries here because there is so much
potential not just
in the small businesses that dominate
northern ireland's economy like my mums
but also in the industries of the future
with hydrogen buses coming on the
streets
with the space propulsion center with
talles with city here with the financial
services industry i know how to turbo
charge
those industries
i was radical as chancellor i will be
radical as prime minister reforming our
financial services regulation making
sure that we create the innovation
economy of the future spreading r d
across the uk
creating a new freeport right here in
northern ireland a brexit opportunity
that i came up with now i know with my
business experience i can lead not just
northern ireland's economy but the uk's
economy into the future and seize those
opportunities that are there waiting for
us if we're prepared to be bold and
radical about grasping them
because in two years we need to
reunite our country at a general
election and we have to do something
that has never been done before
we have to make british political
history by winning a fifth general
election in a row
now
even
even though it hasn't been done i am
confident that working together all of
us we can do it
but it's going to require us to appeal
to swing voters everywhere
and we need to start right here because
it's right
that the conservativist unionist party
puts resources and candidates in every
part of our united kingdom because we
want to win in every part of our united
kingdom
but
in order to that win that election we
will have to appeal to people everywhere
and i am passionate
that i am the candidate that offers our
party the best opportunity
of securing that election victory and
ensuring that kia starmer never walks
through the doors of number 10 downing
street
and
in conclusion i'll just say this you saw
me as chancellor at the beginning of the
pandemic acting boldly radically to
successfully safeguard
our economy
through the biggest storm it had
experienced in 300 years
now as prime minister
i promise you that i will apply that
same sense of urgency and grip to
everything else that government does
as we create a better britain
a britain where our children can walk
safely on the streets at night a britain
where the nhs is reformed and efficient
and there for us when we need
a britain where our schools and
apprenticeships are the envy of the
world in providing opportunity and of
britain where our economy is the most
dynamic it has ever been with our
businesses investing and innovating to
create jobs in every part of our country
but i also promise you this perhaps more
importantly that i will give you my all
to ensure that each and every one of you
here today
can always feel
enormously proud
of the conservative government that i
will be privileged to lead
so i humbly ask for your support not
just to be
our next party leader but also the next
prime minister of our great united
kingdom thank you
thank you
right we're straight into questions once
again if you can raise your hands
there's a lady down here we'll go for
the lady on the end
first of all
if the microphone is coming down to you
and now
hi lynn anderson east belfast how
exactly are you going to sort out the
nhs issues
gps working part-time lack of gps
intakes not
managing to take over those leaving i'm
a former nurse and i've seen all the
issues firsthand on sunday night there
were two emergency psychiatric beds but
they were mattresses on the floor
what are you going to do
yeah
so lynn
that the nhs is the country's number one
priority and it's clearly under strain
and
if we want to be a government that cuts
taxes
and i desperately want to deliver tax
cuts for you and everyone else in the
country
we have to be prepared to be bold about
the nhs because if we are not
if we're not prepared to do things
differently the nhs will continue to
swallow up every pound that every one of
you here and everyone else has
right and i think we as conservatives
need to try and change that dynamic we
need to reform and make the nhs more
efficient so we can talk less about how
much money we're always putting into it
and more about the health care that
we're getting out of it
so i'm going to prepare i'm prepared to
be very very radical about these things
and i'll give you just one example so
you get a sense that i've been thinking
about this and that's to tackle an issue
which has bedeviled us for years and we
haven't done anything about and that is
the issue of missed nhs appointments
now last year across the nhs there were
15 million
appointments that were missed not just
at gps but at hospitals too
and that's not right doesn't value our
doctors and nurses and worse it deprives
people of the care that they desperately
and urgently need so my plan is to get
tough on people who are missing
appointments
because if we do that it's not about
making money from them it's about
changing behavior in this country so
that's not acceptable
because if people cancel those
appointments in advance
we will free up an enormous amount of
extra health care which means people can
get seen quicker they won't be waiting
we'll get the backlogs down faster
without a single one of you
or anyone else having to pay a penny
more in taxes
and yes lots of people will say well you
can't be tough on people and there's
always a good excuse or how will you get
the charging to work but no
right we've got to do things differently
and take on these conventions because if
we don't if we're not prepared to be
bold and radical about getting
efficiency out the nhs not only will we
not get the health care that we need and
deserve we will never be able to cut
taxes and i want to do both of those
things so that's what i'm going to
deliver for you as prime minister
there's a lady just here
hi uh leslie mcgardy northdime
i'm a social care provider of over 30
years standing and i have never known it
to be so difficult to deliver social
care
there are two aspects to my question the
first one is in relation to
benefits that
prevent people from working or permit
them not to work
and secondly in relation to immigration
costs for
social care businesses
presently we are unable to retain staff
recruit staff who are currently on
universal credit
uh we can't
improve their terms and conditions
because then it reduces their benefits
with there being mileage perhaps and
increasing the number of hours that
people have to work in order to obtain
universal credit
and secondly i have to pay three and a
half thousand pounds to the home office
to bring staff from overseas
these staff will be doing work for the
nhs to the public sector whilst they're
employed by me
is that fair
so it's an excellent question because
some of the challenges that you're
seeing in social care
are being felt across the economy and
many of you will run small businesses
and what's the number one challenge
other than energy costs is getting
access to workers and getting people to
actually work and i strongly believe
that part of the answer to this problem
is being much tougher on our welfare
system to get people off benefits and
into work
now i'll tell you this right now there
are more people claiming unemployment
benefit
then there are job vacancies in the
economy i mean just think about that for
a second and that's happening under a
conservative government that's clearly
not right something's gone wrong now i
think there are one or two very specific
things we can do to change now actually
your idea is similar to one that i'm
going to put in place right now
if you're an unemployment benefit and
you work just nine hours on the national
living wage
at that point
you don't have to check in as much with
your job coach at the job centre
you don't have to take the extra hours
that may be on offer or an extra job and
you can keep your benefits nothing
happens to you i don't think that's
right right because ultimately it's your
taxes and someone who's working very
hard taxes that are paying for that and
if there are hours to do if there's a
job going people should have to take the
job
as opposed to just being able to stay on
benefits and that's the change that i
want to bring because i do think that is
the right thing it's the conservative
thing those are our values we believe in
working hard
right and we want to support people off
welfare into work because it's good for
them and their families too because
there's dignity in work i passionately
believe that and it's fair for taxpayers
and it's good for the economy because it
will ease inflation so it's something i
want to be very robust on and quickly
because it's the right thing to do but
as long as we're doing that
and as long as we're being tough on
illegal migration which i talked about
in my speech which we must do
and i will do
then i think it's right that we are
pragmatic about migration for those
sectors of our economy that need support
so whether that may well be in
agriculture or social care where we have
as you know
put
social care workers on the
immigration shortage list i think it's
perfectly reasonable to be pragmatic
because brexit for me and i voted for
brexit proudly was about having control
over our borders not saying that no one
should ever come here but making sure
that everyone who did come here
comes here for a reason that we decided
that's what sovereignty means and that's
the kind of country and immigration
system and welfare system that i want to
deliver as prime minister
um the gentleman
next to the gentleman who's holding up a
handkerchief a
[Laughter]
sdi sdi under the united nations i'm
from hong kong
hi welcome here and
thanks for
um being here um
nowadays um i believe that putin
is not quite strong as some half year
ago we all believe that
but our greatest
flat maybe still
beijing
xi jinping got
65 percent
getting away in
october and october if you believe me
and regardless of that
there are something called
transcendental
warfare i don't know whether
uh
we are all ready for that including
question sir please
including
the war now including hong kong and
including
the
[Music]
taiwan
taiwan technology semiconductor are we
ready
to counter beijing
yes well look sir i agree with you and
i've said so previously that china
represents in the chinese communist
party represent the greatest threat to
our economic security and indeed our
national security that's something that
the head of mi5 and the fbi also
affirmed in a recent speech that they
jointly gave and you're right as well
that threat manifests itself in lots of
different ways and in new ways to those
that we were used to dealing with in the
past so well how do we deal with it i
think there are a number of things that
i will leave with you
first of all you mentioned investment
and that's right now
it's a great strength of our economy
that we are open to international
investment and it has driven jobs growth
and productivity which you all know
here in northern ireland but it's also
right that we are able to protect
ourselves against hostile investment
that seeks to steal our technology
infiltrate our companies and that's why
as chancellor is proud to pass a new law
the national security investment act
which gives us new powers to stop that
type of hostile investment from
happening as prime minister i would
absolutely use the powers in that bill
to keep us all safe but we need to do a
few other things we need to always stand
up for our values particularly with
regard to hong kong as you said and
that's why i talked about our country's
proud compassionate history and
welcoming people here
fleeing persecution and i want us to
always be able to do that as we did in
hong kong where that means
being in control of illegal migrations
people have trust in the system it means
being an active security presence in the
region and our aircraft carrier recently
was there
and in partnership with the australians
and the americans we have a new defense
partnership and lastly we need to be
thinking about the strategic threats
that face us in years and decades to
come we'll all be driving electric
vehicles probably one day that will be
wonderful on many levels but it won't be
wonderful if all the rare earth minerals
that power the electric batteries will
come from china will it so we need to be
thinking right now as i was as
chancellor working with my counterparts
in australia america and canada
to build a supply chain of those
critical minerals which is not reliant
on china and we don't leave that too
late so those are all the ingredients
that go into countering the threat but
let me just close on this because it's a
broader question about defense spending
now look i was the chancellor who
together with the defense secretary and
prime minister put in place the largest
uplift in defence spending since the end
of the cold war and we did that in the
middle of the pandemic we singled them
out for special treatment because the
threats our country facing
were increasing and we wanted to make
sure that the mod was resourced
appropriately for those
now if liz was here well when was liz i
don't know if you asked her but she
would say that she's going to commit to
three percent of gdp on defense spending
i'm not going to do that
right defense spending is going to
increase of course it is and it will
continue to do so but i don't believe in
arbitrary targets when it comes to
something as important as security of
our realm so i'll make a different
commitment to you that i will invest
whatever it takes to keep you your
families and our country safe because
that's the first duty of a prime
minister and it's certainly the first
duty of a conservative and unionist
prime minister
i'm gonna go front row this gentleman
here the microphone is on its way
hi richard you're in houston from east
belfast um
this country has
some excellent anti-slavery legislation
and is against the use of child labour
and you mentioned the rare earth metals
my concern is that with the the
government's obsession with net zero
and trying to push us all into electric
cars
what can you do to ensure that child
labour is not being used in africa china
etc to to mine the precious metals that
are necessary to create the electric
cars we're supposed to buy yeah well
[Applause]
it's an excellent question and it's
probably something you're more familiar
with than i am and my understanding is
there are a bunch of international
conventions that we are a party to that
govern the use of child labour in supply
chains not just for for mining but in
all sorts of other things but i'll
happily go and look at that because if
there's a particular exposure in in the
mining side for rare earth minerals that
is not as well covered as for example
clothing supply chains which we did a
lot of work on over the past 20 years
i'd happily go and take a look at that
because ultimately that's something that
we all care deeply about and all of us
share those share those values but if i
may you mentioned a slight uh point
about net zero which i probably should
address look um i i believe in net zero
right i have two young girls and they're
nine and eleven and for the past couple
of years they have not really been
bothered at all about the job i've had
with one exception is that they say to
me daddy what are you doing about the
environment right and this big important
job you have that's the only thing they
care about so look i do think it's
important and in the same way that you
heard me talk passionately about
the public finances and what we leave
our kids and our grandkids i think as
conservatives we care about inheritance
in all its
guises and part of our inheritance that
we leave the next generation is the
environment so i think it's right that
we care about it but you're also right
we need to do it in a way that's
pragmatic and that brings people along
with us so my answer to doing that is
simple
it's about innovation because if we're
going to get there in a way that means
we're not all just giving everything up
that we love doing that our bills are
not endlessly increasing we need
innovation we need british scientists
and researchers and companies to create
the products
of the future that will help provide
clean reliable affordable secure energy
for us all to use and that is happening
right hydrogen buses as i said on the
streets just here in in northern ireland
that's fantastic it's a glimpse of what
is possible and we need to do that
across the board in solar and new
nuclear real actors and offshore wind
you name it and i'm confident we can do
it why because i know how to build an
innovation economy that's what my
business background has been in that's
when i spent time in california i know
all the ingredients it takes
to build an economy that will put
innovation at its heart because not only
do we need to do that
to solve net zero we also need to do
that to create jobs and prosperity for
every part of our united kingdom because
that's what modern economies are built
on if you want to drive growth in a
modern economy yes tax is important and
we can talk about it and we should but
that is only a bit of the story in this
day and age if you do not have an
economy that is the most innovative in
the world we will not be able to be one
of the fastest growing economies in the
world and that is the economy that i
know how to build for all of you here in
northern ireland and the united kingdom
and that's how we're going to do net
zero in a positive way and that's how
we're going to spread jobs and
opportunity around our country
so i'm going to go to the gentleman on
the end of the road there next
hi tournament scott south belfast hi i
just want to ask what are you going to
do for those who are not protected by an
energy price cap whether it be a small
business a pharmacy a school a care home
they're not protected by a press cap
what are you going to do for them now
when their prices and their bills are
skyrocketing
yeah so look well part of the the reason
is that it gets passed through so the
reason part of the reason inflation that
all of us are seeing is as of this
morning 10
is because businesses largely pass on
prices through that's how a market
economy works and the most effective
thing for us to do is to help people now
look i think there are some major
reforms we need to make to the energy
market right now i'll give you one
example again without getting into the
detail that will reduce wholesale costs
for business all the people you
mentioned and that's in the electricity
market right now
the price that we pay for electricity
and all those people you mentioned paper
electricity is too high it's
artificially inflated why because think
about it we get electricity from an
offshore wind turbine right
did anything change in the last year
about the cost for that
particular business no nothing changed
costs the same to produce the offshore
wind this year as it did last year but
the price we're paying
for that electricity
has quadrupled because we have to pay
the price of natural gas
right that's how our market works it
looks at who's got the highest price and
right now because of a war it's natural
gas and then we have to pay everyone
else that price that's not right and we
need to reform our market to break that
link and if we can do that it will
significantly lower wholesale
electricity prices for all of the people
that you spoke about and all of us
that's a reform that we are behind on
europe has already moved ahead of that
and i want to get on as prime minister
and crack on and deliver that but i will
take this other point if you don't mind
about people because this is really
important it's the most important issue
facing our country in the short term is
how are we going to get through this
winter i think millions of people are at
risk of a very tough time and i've been
very clear that my plan is to support
them now i believe we have to support
vulnerable groups those on low incomes
and pensioners directly with financial
support because a tax cut does not work
for those people
so if you know liz's plan is to say well
i believe in tax cuts not direct support
i don't think that's right
because her tax cut for someone on her
salary means 1 700 pounds of help for
someone working really hard
on the national living wage in the care
sector that we took talk about or indeed
you did
that tax cut is worth about a pound a
week
for a pensioner
who's not working that tax cut is worth
precisely zero
right so that's not a plan that i think
is right for our country if we don't
directly help those vulnerable groups
those people on the lowest incomes those
people pensioners
then it will be a moral failure of the
conservative government and i don't
think the british people will forgive us
for that and it's not something that i
would ever do as prime minister because
the wrong thing to do
okay
so we're going to go to the lady here
with a hand up
thank you hi i'm jane doherty from our
mom and relatively new member
welcome jane i just want to ask you uh
hear your answer to your question that
was asked to liz truss was very much on
the minds of people of northern ireland
is the constant impasse in government
and government not sitting in northern
ireland or as we call it our house
strategic huffing
and
all these great policies that you've
mentioned
can't really be put in place effectively
if we do not have our government sitting
so i want to know what specific actions
measures or laws you are going to put in
place if you become prime minister so
this does not go on thank you yeah well
look i i i think on this there's there's
probably not an enormous amount of
disagreement between it lives on this
question i think all of us want to see
institutions back up and running right
that's the right thing for the people of
northern ireland and you know when we
think about
how far we've come right 25 years next
year right of the belfast good friday
agreement and for this not to be
functioning is sad right it's not what
any of us wanted it's not what should be
happening and i think there's so much
promise i just you know there was a
festival just a few months ago that i
was reading about the four corners
festival that brought people from
communities together with words from not
just the pope but also the archbishop of
canterbury you can't imagine that
happening 25 years ago so look there's
so much progress that has been made and
we need to make sure that we fix this so
that we can continue moving into the
future so look that starts with fixing
the protocol right and it also starts
with talking to all parties and making
sure that we can try and resolve
differences and bring people together
that's what i would do as prime minister
i'm sure it's what liz would do as well
both of us are committed to passing the
bill that is in parliament but look you
know as well as i do that bill will take
time
right that bill will take time to pass
so in the interim of course as a new
prime minister i would seek to talk to
europe and ireland and the french to see
if we can find a negotiated outcome i've
got a track record in doing that i have
good relationships with all my
counterparts across the board because a
negotiated outcome if it's there and
history shows us that even when europe
say they're not open to changing
anything they have because if that
negotiated outcome is there it will be
far quicker than waiting for the bill to
pass so it's worth at least trying but
be in no doubt about my resolve to fix
the situation with the protocol which i
think will unlock the the power sharing
and bring people back together because
like all of you it's right that you know
your institutions are the one that are
taking decisions on your behalf
especially with the challenges that are
mounting up whether it's with your
next-door neighbor's question about the
nhs at the beginning or social care or
the energy crisis it's right that we
have people here taking decisions for
the people of northern ireland that's
what you deserve and that's what i would
do my best to deliver
sadly that's all we have time for will
you please show your appreciation to
rishi sooner
thank you very much
thanks very much
thank you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
for attending i hope those of you who
haven't already voted it's given you
some food for thought can i reiterate
the words of peter booth at the start of
the meeting can you please ensure that
you vote ideally online but if you're
voting by post you get in the post as
soon as possible we are of course
expecting a royal mail strike so thank
you very much for attending it's been
lovely to see you all
you